so you know what's your role here at
Khan Academy my role at Khan Academy is
an international market development so
what does that mean international market
development means our team is thinking
really hard about how to make Khan
Academy really useful for students
outside of the US and so you can imagine
that there are a lot of students in the
world and the u.s. population it's only
a small sliver of that so how can we
make Khan Academy really useful for
students if you're based in India or if
you're based in Brazil or Mexico or any
other country and I think that's that's
a really hard problem and it's core to
our mission free world-class education
are you real closet anyone anyone
anywhere not just english-speaking
students in the United States with
access to the Internet that is correct
right it's and so wow what does that
mean I mean it's so big of a Tartar that
you have how do you make sense of that
yeah I think we have to dissect the
problem in a lot of ways so one question
that we're asking ourselves is what does
content look like for students in India
and how is that different from the
content that students in the US would
why India India is an interesting
country India has a lot of students a
large proportion of the population is in
the k-12 system and so India is is a is
a country that we want to explore more
because there's so much potential there
did you look at other countries we did
yeah I mean you know it's it's gonna
take us a long time to to hit every
single country but countries where there
is a meant amount of impact that we can
create which means there's a lot of
students there's a lot of teachers and
there's a lot of desire to learn so by
looking at but by looking at the number
of students are coming to Khan Academy
from different parts of the world we see
there's a lot of students coming from
India a lot of students coming from
Brazil Mexico France Turkey
those are all countries where we have
partners so what I'm hearing is I'm we
have some of these places like Brazil
and Turkey and France where we already
have strong partnerships but you are I
guess India is the next thing
India is the next thing right and so
we've been so fortunate in having this
product and having really excited
partners in different countries like
Brazil say we want to help make Khan
Academy more well known same thing for
Mexico and India it kind of is the next
country that we just were so so excited
about and what is that translate to you
like what's your day like like what did
you wait you today or is there a typical
day yeah there is no typical day Khan
Academy is such an awesome place that
you know every day you come in you're
like what is my day gonna look like what
am I gonna learn today
every single day you're gonna learn
something new and your day is I'm going
to look different so if I had to say
what a typical day look like I get in at
around 9:00 a.m. and I start off the day
always reading the news understanding
what's happening in the world because
that's really important how how are
things happening in politics can affect
education how's education can affect
agriculture so trying to connect the
dots so after reading the news we
usually do meetings either with with the
team and working on our strategy so how
are we going to solve problems in
particular countries how are we going to
solve problems with particular content
etc so really working with the entire
organization to to figure out how to
tackle big problems that we have coming
our way and then there are a lot of
meetings with external partners on so
organizations that are so excited about
Khanna counties and Khan Academy's
mission that come and say how can we
work together and so having a lot of
those meetings which is always fun
because you know that's where a lot of
the creativity happens and we get new
ideas that we can explore and we have
lunch okay that's the morning that's the
morning and it's 9:05 and then in the
afternoon you know I think we have time
where we just kind of work and process
the things have happened get some of the
ideas down on paper and
and we work out strategies and a
typically wrap up the day at around 5:00
or so and and drive home and think about
the exciting things have happened and
figure out you know what my day is gonna
look like tomorrow and rinse and repeat
what's the hardest thing about this the
hardest thing about this gosh there's so
many things that we can do there's so so
many things that we can do a lot of
great ideas that you know from from from
from different people on the team it's
just a matter of prioritization what do
we want to do first how can we set
ourselves up in the short term to be
successful so that we pave our path for
the long term so you know taking a
hundred ideas and say which three or
four we're gonna focus on today that is
gonna help us be successful in the long
term but not doing those on a 97 think
is hard it is extremely important
especially when you know your service
idea number four looks good it does yeah
and you know if we can have the you know
a team that can that can really execute
on everything one of these ideas great
but I think we also put a lot of
emphasis on focus and being able to do a
few things really really well and how
does someone become you I mean I don't
know I don't remember a major being
offered in college called
you know international market
development elite or something like that
how did you end up here I ended up here
because I think throughout my career you
know I've worked in investment banking
I've worked in accounting I've worked in
as a career counsellor which is a
recruiter I've worked in marketing but
in my entire career path something that
has always been consistent is this
passion for education and just wanting
to use education as the the most
powerful lever to do good in the world
and so I've never really gotten a lot of
passion either you seem very low-energy
I know that the viewers might not
realize it sorry I interrupted no no I
think it's a you know always always you
know understand that education is such
an important part of my life and how
I've gotten here today by having really
great teachers really great resources
and mentors and being able to build as
prod
and build this thing for the world
there's no better place to work than
here and how did you end up here how did
you end I mean particularly it kind of
what were you doing before I gosh my my
career I've worked at universities I've
worked at Microsoft I worked at Google I
worked at a company called Coursera and
I had the fortune of meeting you for
four years ago and learn about Khan
Academy well that didn't make you run
away as fast I know this guy is pretty
interesting and he's easy you know
making these videos and has just such a
such a soothing voice really great ways
of making people understand things and
you know it's really interesting that
four years later we've built this
incredible product that's not just
videos anymore it's exercise it's
interactive exercises that learn that
I've learned how you're learning and
give you a personalized adaptive plan
and so let's take that and you know how
do we make every single person in the
world have access to it I think that's
to me such a hard and exciting and you
know it's going to be a long-term
problem that that we solve and I'm so
excited to be here finally after you
know four years and I feel like this is
like the mecca of we're really cool
ideas intersect with education intersect
with technology that you know can grow
to you the entire I mean you know
seriously what do you expect in ten
years if we if we do another one of
these in ten years what like what do you
think we're gonna reflect back on what
do you think were gonna hopefully have
done you know that this is a really it's
a hard problem and I think ten years
from now right if we were to look back
and say what's Khan Academy successful I
think we want to see the impact that it
has had on people's lives and you know
how do you break that down has it made
an impact on your education do you feel
like your education has improved because
Khan Academy has some small or
significant way has it improved your
career has what you've what will you use
Khan Academy for has it helped you build
confidence in your job and helped you
understand concepts more easily it does
help you fit in better at work because
you more comfortable talking about
specific things and has it had an impact
on your social life I don't know it's an
area right that those videos are coming
soon but maybe because you use Khan
Academy you were able to make friends
and you were able to connect better with
your classmates or your teachers you
know all these things if we can look
back 10 years from now and you know we
interview students you know all you know
hundred plus million students and we get
an assessment from them to say yeah this
has helped me then we've done our job
what kind of scale or reached you do you
hope for at oh well I think Khan Academy
is a product that you can access if you
have internet connection right and
that's something that over the next 10
years we hope everyone has access to the
Internet and so in terms of scale I
imagine that as many people that have
the internet could be using Khan Academy
so eventually if we get there it's gonna
be phenomenal because Khan Academy isn't
just for you know if you're in fourth
grade
it's when you start learning to you know
what's the upper bound the upper bound
is you know whatever you want to make it
retirement planning
yes exactly or beyond yes beyond our
life no I ya know
well thanks for being part of this
adventure it's absolutely a pleasure to
be here